what is happening reject nation it's
Greg Alva here with Kyle I element from
fan theory YouTube channel that's right
fan theory talks games movies for dick
[ __ ] across the platforms Kyle Luhrmann
on Twitter and Instagram - I wanted to
say to you that there's a clueless gamer
out there but Conan Will Arnett loved
clueless gamer you know the game arms
yes you do
yeah I don't go into this clueless
hey television friends we got a very
special treat right now I'm going to be
playing a brand new fighting game for
the Nintendo switch called arms there it
is since it's a head-to-head fighting
game I thought I should fight someone
I've always wanted to destroy publicly
and then I despised enemy he's uh always
a real piece of [ __ ] willing Kelly thank
you guys and then there was an applause
so I'm just a fans of taking selfies and
stuff okay there's no here no fans will
welcome to the bedroom duplicate of my
apartment did you see my sex pad can you
imagine it going driver yes today yeah
you look like the Marlboro Man with
leukemia right here it's called a horn
yeah and we can attack each other with
long arms or arms of made of ramen
noodles you know kind of like gears in a
real-life exam is you can feel this
right now it feels like a soft goulash
a second plate shell which one would you
feel your to try protein and then
repetitions with way to prevent oh my
god
yeah we can zip lock bag and headlight
okay could have a spaghetti sauce and
information a torch
yeah better than this flan sock you have
I said fine play the game yeah um and
you're going to beat down of your life
whoever wins okay yeah makes the other
guy shoot a video that we put online
describing lie the winner is their hero
that would be very difficult for me to
have to do to do that that would require
I probably have to actually become a
decent actor to do that deal
whoever wins and the other person that's
to make what's not okay you just shake
like you just woke up from a coma let's
play
there's Adam players going to step in
and give us an attempt atom which is
atom Aaron and it's Aaron of no users
will bill are Nils Will Arnett I'm will
curious quick question Aaron telling you
worked on the show got his name right
first ride on the way 16 years 16 years
sizzles no weird are you
let's see there okay arm it looks like
just a normal
boxing game it was actually a lot
strategy okay I better put the score
mixer with the staff time so there are
no injuries you need to strap up very
fun okay
I know you again so first thing is I'm
going to pick your character with the
little stick on the blue band there room
in it looks like he's got my kind of
hair teeth bring man keep your pants are
you
are we starting in a box and with death
wieners way to McLintock
it's time for Canadian beatdown me
you're me now
yeah can I do it exhibition now into the
real one USA right just took a check ok
first of all last time it seems like
last time we had a war we act Canada won
I don't remember that one
yes oh here we go oh no like a
chinchilla person okay how I see his
tracks if you find this woman ones se
stone go ahead and I something else is
that you began the match before I was
even right okay what was that
look at that oh that I just said I
wouldn't hate it to have you at Normandy
we have a guy who couldn't beat
[Music]
we're going to take that hill we're
having a run big night on the beach not
touching you're just doing like this
what's this thing you were using even
[Laughter]
you look I can only end up less elbow
and that peoples are we getting tired
welcome you're not getting to see me to
get tired
what happened there what hon what
happened to one I think you're one
because of time the time you in just a
little yeah because I'm time to take the
cat away yeah time is on my side to
quote the Rolling Stones breath they get
much older these strolling bones you
want to move because I could get a guy
in here real quick you know when I was
growing up in Canada yeah I got my top
companies do not like real currency
right what's that means well the queen
is our patient so it's when it's one of
the Queen
I would never do that it sounds like you
are
ah I'm sorry I just showed you my plan
[Music]
count if I was over there and not even
playing
I mean the match was going this time why
didn't you say anything
Arnold I have a inkling as to why he
didn't play you know traitor once you go
over there it's in the corner exchange
alright great closing by the way what
happened so great now by the last time
your popcorn I suspected so much more to
just get in popcorn to your Cobra honey
win just I've been great you can simply
hate me more time to take away more
layout go away battle what you got to do
is you got to hit the opponent your hunt
he's sweating no miss Goodin you want
get in tight okay I've been discovered
spring any kind of sexual sweat no sweat
here identically not sweat how to make a
person you have a hole here three
glasses a sequel to come in
oh hey y'all
oh snap I think that just happened we
get some of the Bligh's forehead if you
start to approach me as if you're going
to give me some of them realize I don't
need any and back away don't play that
oh yeah yeah just did not just move in
like oh and then be like oh no you don't
need it you have to will is winning at
the game yes for childish love games
- I watching this was until that's right
he brought his kicking they're watching
he's a really good guy
well good man and I really respected
[Laughter]
okay I got the results right now and
reveal them everything I'm nervous ma'am
because I don't want to have to make a
video saying I think about you matches
coming one for matches one seven almost
doubles
okay don't like a clump you call on this
double burn sick burns coming had ten
sweet six burns we took one off because
it was a pun will 1100 Colonel Brian
here
the hero it's so great really
good-looking guy the great act area
penalize success then being stabbed
allegedly using super smart oh dude
that's going to be a good hero
[Applause]
don't forget it snap sexy snack code
this number has different chance to win
a Nintendo switch and other great prizes
from our friends at Pepsi and you can
see the other video games I've reviewed
at Team Coco calm slash Poulos gamer
ladies that is probably one of the best
clueless gamers I think I've ever seen I
think it's because normally it's Conan
who's a really funny one and sometimes
he has a guest who's kind of funny with
him but they're usually like a little
weird there's usually not someone who
could rip perfectly off of him yeah I'm
used to just seeing him like learn a
game for the first time and not at all
have any idea what yeah he's doing it
just makes fun of the game yeah and
that's what was interesting about this
one because it was all about him and
Will Arnett battling each other it
wasn't really about making fun of the
game no not only the bit he resorts to
is making fun of everything within the
game yeah and this time it was all about
I didn't really remember unbeatable
like a happen oh man it was good though
I mean yeah I like that he does like
it's like a competitions that I'm just
look at me flail yeah so it was cool I
think he has the best lets place
let's place yeah that's what they call
when they play games on YouTube learn a
thing or two
Kyle I'm learning learn a thing or two
I'm still learning if you want to be
part of the YouTube world you have to
know lingo let's uh play it sound like
you said YouTube world ad pocalypse
plenty of money not to be made I know
about those who bless things you just
meant oh I know all about that
struggling to make rent that is the
YouTube world the dirty guy I loved the
scorecard
I love the whole squaring and how he
kept trying and then I loved when will
well our net one also because he was
like getting several caves and yeah yeah
but it did so good well well or die took
it seriously he does have that
strikingly good boy she's the only
Batman I could think of that doesn't
change his voice when he's Batman I mean
he slightly deepens it so
little bit more he's definitely my
favorite Batman yeah but he still sound
like Will Arnett I feel like everyone
else has to do like now with like when
Batman Annapolis bad yeah go ahead just
have that voice naturally
that's so obvious SEMICON are actually
friends oh yeah absolutely because I
asked you to learn that guests are a lot
on code and I hope that like when you
get to improv masters going at it with
each other when they're just being
themselves that or not playing
characters and that's what it's like
that's an improv my kid you're watching
yeah
I played that game oh you did yeah III
was it's a lot of fun out of all the
games like III this is the one you
picked up oh I played some other games
too but obviously arms doesn't look
interesting at all
it's fun what looks fun about that game
it's a whole different way of fighting
it's a different type of strategies it's
fun
do you know what the word fun me
apparently not means making money on
YouTube
I don't know it's fun me I do I forgot
what it means to in the last two months
yeah I don't care anymore
my channel is at five cents
congratulations I'm catching up to you
subscribers are real rejects if you want
to if you want click that notification
approach on this video with lack of
commentary to click that notification
about Kyle is the Kyle ermine on Twitter
and Instagram all social media across
the board yeah there you go that was his
way of summing up and he has this
channel fan theory channel calm yeah fan
theory channel calm
it's a redirect for you too [ __ ] it's
called fan theory channel comm correct
well you could just type in fan theory
channel calm how do you get that I set
it up brilliant
on day one and we're going to be talking
about how we lost weight on my patreon
take that out take it out